what trip don't give me that look oh
he's here what you said he's coming an
hour from now no he's right on time
Gonzalo hey it's been too long man hello
how are you I sell melons would you like
to buy guess not
come on man let me ingles Allah whatever
spit - yeah yeah yeah yeah where's the
wine
no no here we are dad shrieky boys
Gonzalo
alright guys um this has been great by
the way
you look fabulous
oh why did you say so girl hey I know
I'm fabulous I can't hear you over how
fab I am anyway I can't remember oh I
like your ball
I like your bones I'm not I like your
balls super ace
alright I'm gonna go to the kitchen uh
Gonzalo
are you trying to leave the room again
milk look just come back to the living
room quit screwing around you guys are
mean okay no really don't come again so
come on we really just want you to come
back in here you
you know what no Gonzalo that's it ah
you need to you went through the wall
here superpowers we invited you over but
this is just not let me goat you demon
you demon hunter you off
pieces piece of god damn it I know
I should just take the wine and left
she's here
you never oh yeah it's been so long
since we've seen you
how are you doing I'm pretty good thank
you Ginevra dammit I miss Mike hi hi how
are you I am so happy to see you after
so long that's funny I said the same
thing hilarious